[Music]
what does your dream home look like
a small cabin in the woods maybe a
mansion of glass and stone high up in
the mountains
or a quiet apartment with a view of the
beach whatever it may be
you'll be integrating some tech and
smart home features into your place
because of course you'll need heating
lighting entertainment
and a way to make sure you keep your
carbon emissions to the absolute minimum
today's home design is at a whole other
level
with incredible innovations and
state-of-the-art functions
that promise to ah prospective buyers
some combine convenience and luxury with
eco-friendliness
and make home life simpler today we take
a look at 10 of the most
futuristic homes in the world before we
dive
in make sure you subscribe to the
channel and ring the bell
so you never miss a video on the world
of tech number 10
the heliotrope nestled in the lap of
nature the heliotrope is located in
freiburg germany
it is given the merit of being the first
house in the world
to generate more power than it uses its
energy is entirely renewable
emissions free and carbon dioxide
neutral
the home even rotates to make the most
of the sun's light and heat
using its 6.6 kilowatt dual axis solar
pv
tracking panel a geothermal heat
exchanger a heat and power unit
and solar thermal balcony railings for
hot water
the brainchild of architect ralph dish
this rotating solar home was what
started germany on its movement to solar
energy
the home also has a grey water cleansing
system and a natural compost system for
food waste
it takes an active stance against
wastage and living here would improve
the quality of your lifestyle overall
the heliotrope attempted and succeeded
at creating a living space in tune with
nature
both regarding what goes into the house
and what it gives off
instead of intruding upon nature the
home sits within it
and allows nature to intrude on the
house
this home has won many innovation and
environmental awards
and might be converted into a hotel
sometime in the future
number nine tree in the house designed
by almassaf of amassa architects
tree in the house has the concept of an
inverted tree house
it is intended to be an escape from the
sweltering heat and restrictions of
concrete houses in the city
it features an entirely glazed and
cylindrical structure
allowing 360 degree views of the forest
setting it technically hasn't been built
yet
as the project has experienced a few
setbacks an investor they secured in
backed out but now a glass and solar
panel manufacturer has picked it up
the renderings show the cylindrical
glass structure sitting in a woodland
clearing with the upper stories rising
above the canopy
glazed walls and ceilings reveal four
narrow ring-shaped floors
and a spiral white staircase wrapping
around the tree trunk
the tree's bows extend outwards towards
the glazed walls and roof
so they don't take up much floor space
the glass shower is essentially a
cubicle
and takes after the contours of the
building while other parts of the home
feature freestanding furniture
that follows the curving walls number
eight the echo capsule
beautiful entirely off-grid smart and
self-sustaining
the echo capsule is the one-stop
solution if you're looking for living in
a remote location that's affordable
and environmentally friendly it utilizes
solar and wind energy
and functions as a practical functioning
self-sustaining unit
that you can make into a hotel room a
cottage a research station
or whatever else you want the installed
solar power is 880 watts
and the low noise wind turbine delivers
up to 750
watts during day and night time the
telescopic pole the turbine is mounted
on
is easily foldable so you can take it
anywhere this mobile home's unique shape
also reduces heat loss and collects rain
water on the surface
where it sits in a tank and is filtered
for your use
the walls are made of two layers of
fiberglass with polyurethane foam
sandwiched in between
it weighs 4409 pounds and measures 15 by
7.2 feet
with 88 square feet of interior space
this space is suitable for two people
and it comes with a folding bed a
kitchenette and even storage space
the interiors are done by devin coldway
to evoke a sense of warmth and comfort
but with a futuristic look in addition
to that the echo capsule also has a 4g
data connection
all the smart home features and sensors
you can need and is completely tablet
controlled
number 7. villa epsilon grease this
hyper futuristic looking smart home is
located in an olive grove in southern
peloponnese
it is characterized by its
ipsilon-shaped green roof
that is both an accessible extension of
the terrain and a lookout point for a
stunning view
the project was headed by theo sarantha
glue lalas and dora suede from lhasa
architects
since the house is on top of a hill it
provides vistas towards the bay of skita
and sapienza as well as mountain views
towards the east
you'll find that the height of the home
is limited to the tips of the olive
trees
so it integrates perfectly with its
surrounding the interiors have two main
sections
one is a more private area for bedrooms
and the second is the common area with a
kitchen and living room providing access
to the courtyards since it is in a
remote location and the project had a
limited budget
much of this work was carried out
off-site and assembled which reduced
total construction time to
just seven months this approach also
allowed them to rely less on
off-the-shelf
products and favor locally sourced
materials like terrazzo
and marble number six billionaires
tropical paradise
maybe considerably less affordable than
the echo capsule
this luxury smart home in rancho santa
fe
sits on 12 usable acres of land and is
perfect for those who don't mind
shelling out 18 million bucks to kick
back
and relax in the lap of nature and
technology
for recreation you have your own tennis
court a basketball court
and a sand volleyball court and of
course a swimming pool
and if you're looking for something more
fun there is even a water slide on the
property that leads into the pool
the property also includes all the
equestrian facilities you need if you
like horse riding
the primary residence features 7
bedrooms and 14 bathrooms
across 12 417 square feet of space
it is controlled by the creston home
automation system which is essentially
the brain of the property
it handles everything from the lighting
and heating to security cameras
everything that can be controlled in the
home is controlled with your ipad or
smartphone
but it doesn't only rely on tech marvels
the house boasts some gorgeous classical
architecture too
with barn style hand-crafted beans and
limestone heated floors
not to mention interiors that give you a
cozy warm feeling
number five bill gates home it's no
surprise that the founder of microsoft
would have a smart home
santa do 2.0 as it's called has an
estate-wide server system
a high-tech sensor system helps guests
monitor a room's lighting and climate
if you're a guest in santa do 2.0 you
get a pin
that interacts with the sensors located
all over the house
you can enter your ideal temperature and
lighting preferences and the settings
will change as you move from room to
room
speakers hidden under the wallpaper also
let the music follow you
anywhere you go the home has eighty
thousand dollars worth of computer
screens mounted on the walls
and you can change the display to any
painting or picture you want
the swimming pool even has its own
underwater music system
the house was a collaborative effort of
bowling swinsky
jackson and cutler anderson architects
of bainbridge island
the whole mansion is in pacific launch
style with classic features like a
dome-shaped roof
there are more amenities here like a 2
500 square foot gym
a thousand square foot dining room and a
library in addition to all the
technology the home is filled with
xanadu 2.0 also uses its natural
surroundings to regulate temperature
and reduce heat loss it is an
earth-sheltered house essentially built
into its surroundings
the trees in the property are taken care
of around the clock
still one maple tree in particular is
monitored electronically 24 hours a day
this is gate's favorite tree and if at
any point it becomes too dry
water is automatically pumped into it
number four
modern desert residents by brian foster
this 5 000 square foot mansion in palm
springs california
is the definition of futuristic luxury
the great room is open concept
and there is lots of empty space
throughout showing you the sheer size of
the house
it features a kitchen a living area a
small and elegant water feature and a
fireplace
the kitchen is fully fitted with
high-end appliances and beautiful walnut
cabinetry
what really makes the home look
futuristic is its sweeping contours
both in the architecture and the
interiors the swivel coffee table for
example can move and provide storage for
your magazines or
books the water feature in particular
looks impressive
and it also collects whatever dust comes
into the house
but you don't have to clean the water
yourself of course it comes with a
filtration system that cleans out the
dust itself
these 60 feet of sliding glass pocket
doors
retract into the walls and disappear
completely
leaving nothing between you and the
outdoors the outdoor also has a fully
equipped kitchen
if you want to have a barbecue generally
fireplaces are either a fire pit
or in one corner of the room this one
here juts out into the swimming pool
giving it a unique look the flow of the
water and fire
carries from the indoors to the outdoors
with the same
graceful curves creating this couldn't
have been easy
but the result looks well worth it
number 364
wild wing court las vegas this modern
bungalow
in the ridge's community of las vegas
brings a resort like experience
to your home the design offers privacy
and stunning interiors
not to mention the very latest in smart
home technology
the rainfall feature in the living and
dining area is the
showstopper and makes the home feel more
open and connected to nature but beyond
architecture you find intimate spaces
for drinks and entertaining
all boasting a contemporary look with
the textured fireplaces to chrome finish
fixtures sharp
angles and clean straight lines with
dark tones
make this an elegant space the stunning
backyard can be accessed through
disappearing glass doors which
when retracted connect the inside to the
outside
seamlessly the media room also opens up
to the backyard and offers an
excellent place for entertaining
complete with a bar
the master suite specifically enjoys a
wrap-around terrace with views of the
mountains
and a luxurious spa style bathroom with
a soaking tub
and dry sauna the home also has a
two-way glass wine cellar
mountain views and a contemporary dream
kitchen
number two the sky sphere if you love
tree houses and expert engineering and
you
crave to have your very own space cut
off from the city
the sky sphere is the home for you
designed and built by jono williams
the sky sphere sets a new standard for
futuristic living
complete with app-controlled light
fixtures a voice controlled beer
dispenser in the couch
and something called zombie mode where
the front door automatically locks
and sends a message saying good luck to
your phone the home relies entirely on
solar power for its energy it can
reportedly withstand an
eight and a half magnitude earthquake
and 125 mile per hour winds
and still this home is portable it is
detachable enough
so the owner can uproot it without much
effort it isn't suitable as a long-term
home yet as there is no plumbing and
therefore no bathroom
but williams has added furniture and a
tv making it a perfect
quiet retreat number one the one
bel air at 500 million dollars
this upcoming project in bel air
california will be the only one of its
kind
the one sits on four acres of land and
features a 5
500 square foot master suite a 45 seat
imax theater
five swimming pools a bowling alley and
much much more
the one is being developed by an
ex-hollywood producer nile nami
and architect paul mclean the
construction alone took
seven years and now it's just a matter
of adding some finishing touches to the
interiors
probably the most striking feature in
the home
is the jellyfish room the house will
have a lounge area where the jellyfish
swim around you and surround you
giving a rather calming and therapeutic
experience
the library is unlike any other with led
strip lights and black and white tones
giving it a futuristic look
the interiors are kept minimal so you
can enjoy the open concept the home will
also have a moat
to give the illusion that it's floating
on water this home will be the only one
of its kind
because california recently passed a law
limiting the square footage of homes in
the hollywood and beverly hills area
that makes the one literally the one
which did you like best let us know in
the comments below
if you enjoyed the video make sure you
give it a like and check out more on the
simply tech channel thanks for watching
and we'll see you
next time